for the outside world knowing having  read about Diane's struggle against the  poachers well it was obviously whose  approaches what did it but I don't think  the evidence stacks up I think it was  much more planned and sophisticated than  a thief or a poacher going in something  didn't feel right  everything that could possibly be broken  was broken my god someone was in a rage  you know or someone was looking for  something drawers were pulled open  things had been pulled out it looked  like somebody was looking for something  money wasn't not taken it was a couple  of handguns down there when you don't  take the money when we don't take my gun  when they take anything visible to me  that's two matically exclude tortures  being with people it looks like a setup  it looked like it was done to just make  believe that poachers have done that  [Music]  you